so now let's take a look at the code
that makes up the homepage for this app
so here's the homepage has a couple of
buttons it has the field wakin into your
name you can click the buttons and you
get the greeting and in this case the
greetings are shown just inside an alert
box now one thing I want to emphasize is
that you can have the endpoints API is
and use the api's explorer even if your
application doesn't have a front-end if
it doesn't have a web page or anything
if you're just running complete back-end
service you can use the api's explorer
to test your api's but now on to the
front-end so let's look at the code for
index dot HTML so first of all we
include the file hello j/s which
includes the JavaScript functions that
our web apps going to use in its front
end and then and this is really
important we include this file APIs
google.com slash Deus slash client j/s
this is a file that includes a
JavaScript client library if you don't
include this file you won't be able to
use endpoints in your front-end the
client libraries provide the glue that
lets your app use endpoints so you'll
also notice that after we bring it in
when the onload successful we call the
init function and this and it functions
actually defined in Hello Jes we'll look
at that in just a minute the rest of
this page is not so exciting we have a
heading then we have the field for the
buttons so this one here is input greet
generically and this one here is input
greet by name we also have the field
where we let the user enter their name
and that's the name field and that's
pretty much all this file has one thing
to note though is that the on click of
the button doesn't have a real value
this is actually a fake value so when we
load the page the first time these
buttons don't have any onclick action
set and the reason for that is when
these actions are loaded they're going
to need to use endpoints they're going
to use your endpoint functions and your
endpoint functions can't be loaded
until after the Google client library is
loaded so you want to load the Google
client library first and then you need
to initialize some things and then you
can set the action for your bar
okay let's take a look at hello Jas so
up here these are just some good
resources to read after the Google
JavaScript client library is loaded then
listen it function is going to be called
and really all this does is it loads
your hello world endpoints api's so you
hear this gap you client load this is
calling functions in the Google
JavaScript client library to load your
endpoint function so when you call gap e
dot client to load your endpoint
functions you specify the endpoint
functions to load specify the version
you specify a callback to call after
your endpoint functions have loaded and
then you must specify the route path
which is the path to your endpoints API
and you can construct that route path
like this which is basically wherever
your apps running ad /a h slash api now
if you leave off the route path the load
function will work or it'll seem to work
but when you go to call your endpoints
api's the execution calls won't work and
that's because the Google client library
will be looking in the Google public
api's instead of looking at the endpoint
api's for your app so do make sure you
specify the root path okay so after we
load the hello world endpoints API we're
going to call the load callback function
here's the load callback very simple it
just enables the buttons it might do
other things in other apps but here all
we do is enable the buttons the enable
button function uses straight-up
JavaScript to set the actions on the
buttons so we get the button that you
clicked greet generically and we set the
onclick action to be the greet
generically function and then we change
the value of the button the label of the
button so that the user knows that it's
ready for action and then similarly we
get the greet by name button and we set
the action when it's clicked to be greet
by name and again we change the label
and just a reminder that we enable the
buttons here instead of setting them in
index dot HTML because these functions
greet generically
and greet by name won't be active until
after the
hello world endpoints API has been
loaded and you can't load that until
after you've loaded the JavaScript
client library so you don't want the
user to be clicking on the buttons
before everything's ready okay so more
interestingly the greet generically
function illustrates how to issue a call
to an to one of your own endpoint API so
you construct the request you need to
start with gap your client you specify
the endpoints API to call which in this
case is hello world endpoints and then
the actual functional method which is
say hello so you construct the request
and then you execute the request and
that's all you have to do to issue the
call you also need to specify a callback
to call to process the response when the
request is executed and similarly greet
by name does the same thing only here we
get the name out of the name field we
issue the request gappy dot client dot
hello world endpoints dot say hello and
here we do pass the name to the request
and this is how you construct parameters
to endpoint functions specify the
parameter and then the value and you
could add if we had more you could add
more here so for example you could add a
second Arg Arg 2 and specify the value
to be value 2 and then again you execute
the request we're going to call the same
call back when our request is successful
okay so here's the callback that gets
called when our request is executed
successfully and we process the response
and the response is always passed to the
callback in this case all we do is throw
up a dialog box you see alert function
throw up a dialog box and get the
message field out of the response and
going back real quick to the Java to the
hello class
recall that the hello class has message
field the hello world endpoint API that
we've defined so far or return a hello
class object so our response is going to
have a message field so now you know how
to define endpoint functions in Java and
how to call them from JavaScript in your
UI